ganze landstriche unter wasser
dörfer entlang der küste fast komplett
ausgelöscht menschen retteten sich auf
dächer und in baumkronen diese bilder
aus mosambik vom märz 2009 10 gingen um
die welt
aber wie sieht es heute aus nach dem
verheerenden zyklon idee wir sind in das
land im südosten afrikas gereist wir
haben menschen getroffen die alles
verloren haben die buchstäblich kein
dach mehr über dem kopf haben
wir haben mit hilfsorganisationen und
ärzten gesprochen haben aber auch
geschichten die wirklich mut machen
nach zyklon ideen eine reportage aus
einem vergessenen land
[Musik]
die katastrophe braut sich über dem meer
zusammen und vierter märz 2009 10
beobachten meteorologen ein
tiefdruckgebiet das vom indischen ozean
auf die küste mosambiks zusteuert und
der sturm wird immer gewaltiger zehn
tage später fegt der zyklon mit fast 200
stundenkilometern über die küstenstadt
bedrückt die wassermassen in die flüsse
die flüsse treten über die ufer hinzu
kommt tagelanger regen dann zieht weiter
nach simbabwe
nur sechs wochen später folgt zyklen
kenne er vor allem den norden mosambiks
trifft am ende kommen in der region mehr
als tausend menschen ums leben
wir fliegen in die ehemalige
portugiesische kolonie
das ziel wäre die zweitgrößte stadt
mosambiks mit mehr als 500.000
einwohnern schon beim landeanflug sehen
wir auch heute ein jahr nach der
katastrophe haben viele gebäude immer
noch kein dach sowie das ehemalige
elternhaus von jessica philipp deponiert
die 19-jährige steht zusammen mit ihren
kleinen schwestern in den trümmern
hier war mal das zuhause der 3 zyklon
hat nur ein paar wände verschont jessica
kümmert sich allein um ihre sieben und
acht jahre alten geschwister der vater
hat die familie früh verlassen
die mutter ist 2013 gestorben und durch
den sturm verlieren die mädchen auch
noch das haus
es war sehr traurig es war sechs uhr
abends da sind wir ins haus meines
cousins gegangen und haben da geschlafen
als wir am nächsten tag aufgewacht und
hierher zurückgekommen sind haben wir
gesehen dass das haus eingestürzt war
also wartet ihr glücklicherweise nicht
zu hause seitdem leben jessica klee
russia und demeter abwechselnd bei
verwandten
die kleinen mädchen gegen jeden morgen
zur schule jessica möchte studieren aber
dafür fehlt das geld schwestern des
franziskanerordens die die familie mit
reis und speiseöl versorgen haben angst
die kluge 19 jährige könne in der
prostitution landen
was brauchen die menschen heute am
nötigsten ich denke die menschen
brauchen vor allem stabile häuser
wellblech für die dächer nahrungsmittel
die menschen haben hunger seit dem
zyklon hat es nicht mehr geregnet es
fehlt der regen wir haben eine
trockenheit wir können nichts an
pflanzen
zweimal in der woche verteilen die
franziskaner schwestern reis speiseöl
und zucker an insgesamt 1500 familien
die vom sturm betroffen sind besonders
im auge haben sie die kinder in 40
prozent von ihnen sind unterernährt auf
das haus von rosa augusto liegt auf der
route der schwestern die 49 jährige
steht vor ihrer hütte die der zyklon
schwer beschädigt hat
hier lebt sie zusammen mit ihrem mann
und acht kindern etwa zehn quadratmeter
zehn personen wo schlaft ihr fragen wir
sie unter dieser plan sagt hoose damals
als der zyklon kam bin ich gerade aus
dem haus raus gegangen ich war hinter
dem gebäude als es dann einstürzte und
das kind war drin
ich hatte dann angst mein sohn er war
unter das einstürzende material gekommen
aber ich habe ihn raus gezogen und dann
sind wir in eine hilfs unterkunft
bekommen
zum glück bleiben alle unverletzt eine
zeit lang wohnt die ganze familie bei
nachbarn
doch dann findet die 49 jährige diese
plane einer britischen hilfsorganisation
die ersetzt bis heute das dach seitdem
wohnen die zehn wieder hier und rosa hat
keine hoffnung mehr jemals wieder unter
einem richtigen dach zu schlafen
was wünsche ich mir für die kinder
ich hoffe dass sie mal studieren
vielleicht ingenieur werden oder
fußballspieler dass sie gesund sein
ich denke es ist das wichtigste durch
das hochwasser nach dem zyklon
verbreiten sich fäkalien schnell bricht
die cholera aus offiziell leiden in den
wochen nach idee 6000 menschen an der
durchfallerkrankung doch die ärzte
können sich nicht um alle kümmern denn
auch krankenhäuser sind durch den sturm
beschädigt wie das gesundheitszentrum
der katholischen universität von berra
wir haben damals im universitätsgebäude
gearbeitet auf dem flur
die uni hatte die türen für uns geöffnet
der zyklon hat viele geräte zerstört
[Musik]
doch wenige tage nach der katastrophe
sind mehr als 70 hilfsorganisationen in
mosambik der kleine flughafen von beta
wird zum umschlagplatz für
internationale lieferungen medikamente
medizinische geräte impfstoffe die
größten epidemien sind schnell
eingedämmt und heute das
gesundheitszentrum in bebra macht einen
guten eindruck schon drei monate nach
dem sturm wird es wieder eröffnet vom
behandlungsraum über die apotheke bis
zum kleinen operationssaal alles wieder
in schuss auch dank spendengeldern
gesammelt von der deutsch
mosambikanischen gesellschaft aber noch
immer können die ärzte nicht alle
hygiene standards einhalten
wir können das so typisch der kino
stehen
das müssen wir extern machen lassen
manchmal kommen die sachen nicht
rechtzeitig zurück ein schwerpunkt der
arbeit des gesundheitszentrums der kampf
gegen aids in mosambik ein riesenproblem
zwölf prozent der erwachsenen sind
hiv-positiv etwa anderthalb millionen
menschen
das konzept der ärzte in bayern sie
machen mit den infizierten gleich
termine für die ganze familie
wir versuchen die fälle von aids zu
reduzieren indem alle hiv patienten
schnell behandelt wir wollen dass sie
sich bei uns gut aufgehoben für das
problem ist dass wir die patienten nicht
erreichen können wenn sie eine woche
oder einen monat lang nicht zur
behandlung ihrer super special treatment
hier in einem provisorischen zelt impfen
die ärzte kinder gegen krankheiten wie
masern röteln und kinderlähmung die
cholera bälle in folge des sturms ist
mittlerweile zwar eingedämmt fast eine
millionen us amerikaner haben die
schluckimpfung bekommen aber natürlich
bilden dreck um schmutziges wasser
weiterhin den nährboden für viele
krankheiten wie hier im slum von motto
wir sind dem foto in bebra das ganze auf
einer ehemaligen müllhalde entstanden
das sieht man auch noch es liegt
wahnsinnig viel müll rum man riecht es
auch noch überall glasscherben und
mittendrin spielen die kinder barfuß
kaum vorstellbar hier leben zu müssen
ein slum auf einer müllkippe
aber hier ist die heimat von elena
gräser die 20-jährige haus mit ihrer
familie und der tante in dieser hütte
sechs personen in zwei zimmern ohnehin
unhaltbare hygienische zustände
doch durch den zyklon wurde alles noch
schlimmer war sehr traurig fürchterlich
da dachten wir so können wir nicht leben
wie machen wir das
und als wir das haus verlassen haben
bedarf es gelesen sturm und er wurde
immer stärker und es war dunkel
es gab keinen strom mehr wir dachten das
wäre das ende
und wohin seid ihr dann gegangen
nach dem sieg nun konnten wir an vaters
arbeitsplatz unterkommen eine weile zwei
wochen lang dann kamen wir zurück
ein paar gassen weiter
dieser berg aus unrat kokett an mehreren
stellen und nur wenige meter entfernt
haben die bewohner des townships einen
brunnen gebaut
ein brunnen aus autoreifen den zugang zu
sauberem trinkwasser haben die vereinten
nationen vor wenigen jahren zu einem
grundrecht erklärt
aber hier in mosambik hat jeder zweite
kein sauberes trinkwasser
die wasseraufbereitung ist für die
hilfsorganisationen ein wichtiger teil
ihrer arbeit
sauberes trinkwasser medikamente nahrung
das fehlt in mosambik in den wochen nach
dem zyklon mittlerweile versuchen die
hilfsorganisationen den menschen
langfristig zu helfen
wir fahren auf der landstraße in 6
richtung simbabwe in einer kleinen
siedlung wollen wir uns mit einer
mitarbeiterin der welthungerhilfe
treffen
doch erst mal wundern wir uns dass es
dort in den engen gassen schon morgens
plötzlich so lautet eine kleine siedlung
100 menschen im hinterland von bera
wir laufen hier durch die hauptgasse
runde von mir weil menschen und reibt
sich die zeit offenbar mit kino das tier
töten und ein wahnsinniger kraft
hier gibt es im umkreis von 100 metern
gleich vier kinos die sich gegenseitig
mit gesteuertem ton konkurrenz machen
auf alten röhrenfernsehern laufen
abgenudelte hollywood schinken
der eintritt kostet umgerechnet 18
[Musik]
gleich nebenan
dieser kleine supermarkt an dem wir
sandra schuckmann honsel von der
welthungerhilfe treffen
sie betreut das so genannte cash and
water programm für 5000 haushalte in der
region mit dieser karte können
notleidende menschen in 15 kleinen läden
kaufen was sie möchten
wenn wir sachleistungen verteilen dann
würden wir als ngo die menge und auf die
qualität bestimmen
der vorteil von diesen karten ist
einfach dass wir die familien dazu
ermutigen trotzdem ihr leben
selbstbestimmt in die hand zu nehmen und
nur weil eine katastrophe passiert ist
müssen sie trotzdem weiter ihr leben
leben und das bedeutet natürlich auch
dass wir ihre würde achten
auf der karte sind pro familie
umgerechnet 50 euro im monat
das projekt wird finanziert von der
europäischen union batterien
das verbessert mein leben ohne den
browser krieg ich mir das alles nicht
leisten
[Musik]
sandra schuckmann honsel hat den zyklon
selbst erlebt allerdings im nachbarland
malawi ich war zu der zeit gerade mit
einer kollegin in malawi in der
hauptstadt lilongwe
und wir haben einen workshop moderiert
zum thema katastrophenvorsorge und
während wir das gemacht haben ist quasi
diese flut und dann später auch der
zyklon ideal passiert das heißt ihre
aufgabe hat sich dann spontan ja ganz
genau also wir standen plötzlich vor der
herausforderung zu handeln wir konnten
mit hilfe des deutschen auswärtigen
amtes ein projekt ins leben gerufen wo
wir halt baumaterialien verteilt haben
und mobile toiletten und handwerk
anlagen und zudem halt auch solaranlagen
um halt sicherzustellen dass zum
beispiel die frauen und mädchen die halt
während der nacht die toiletten
aufsuchen dann auch geschützt sind und
das wurde dann halt alles gut
ausgeleuchtet zurück in bebra wir sind
im township praia nova das armenviertel
liegt direkt an der küste und es liegt
unterhalb des meeresspiegels sowie die
hälfte aller slums in der stadt was das
bedeutet erzählt uns die 17-jährige
kamel arica diener pedro kommt gerade
von der schule nach hause und kam wieder
lebt zusammen mit ihrer mutter und zwei
schwestern in dieser hütte
es ist schwierig natürlich ist das keine
gute gegen wir haben probleme mit der
flut und überschwemmungen
manchmal tritt wasser in die häuser ein
das ist nicht einfach
natürlich würde ich gern woanders wohnen
aber wir haben keine alternative und
darin wohnen wir hier
[Musik]
die regierung will das komplette viertel
praia nova nun zwangsräumung
die menschen sollen ins hinterland
ziehen denn hier ist es zu gefährlich
sollte es zu einem weiteren zyklon und
einem hochwasser kommen während dieser
menschen wieder betroffen
doch trotz dieser gefahr der zerstörung
und der armut in allen slums die wir
besuchen strahlen und die menschen an
der optimismus der bewohner beeindruckt
um die menschen arbeiten in der näherei
im friseursalon oder verkaufen popcorn
überall läuft musik und kinder flitzen
herum
[Musik]
wir spüren dass es den menschen in
bayern gut tut dass ich endlich wieder
jemand für sie interessiert
denn die weltweite aufmerksamkeit nach
der katastrophe war schnell vorbei
auch die verantwortlichen im rathaus von
b hoffen dass mosambik nicht vergessen
wird vom dach des gebäudes aus sehen wir
wie viele häuser in der stadt noch
beschädigt sind alleine 180 öffentliche
gebäude hat der sturm zerstört sagt uns
der stellvertretende bürgermeister
er behauptet dass viele versprochene
hilfsgelder nicht in mosambik angekommen
sind die menschen die ihr leben haben
bis heute keine dächer klar es gibt
alternativen plan
aber das sind provisorien
übergangslösung wir die kommunal
regierung und die menschen erwarten wir
warten auf damals nach dem zyklon gab es
alle versprechungen die gemacht wurden
das größte problem ist dass die küste
nicht geschützt ist
ohne küstenschutz werden wir hier nicht
sicher sein wenn wir nichts tun sind wir
zu künftigen ereignissen hilflos
ausgeliefert
wir konfrontieren den stellvertretenden
bürgermeister damit dass sich
internationale geldgeber wegen der
starken korruption aus mosambik
zurückziehen aber darauf geht er kaum
ein
ist ja auch was sagen wir
es wurden versprechungen gemacht dass
wir die infrastruktur wieder aufbauen
können
ob es da widerstand gibt wegen der
korruption
das kann ich jetzt nicht beantworten wir
spüren dass in mosambik niemand aufs
thema korruption angesprochen werden
möchte aber es stellt ein riesiges
problem dar sagt uns der politologe
alfredo money zahl von der pädagogischen
hochschule ph die korruption helfe vor
allem der staatspartei frelimo die seit
der unabhängigkeit des landes 1975 ohne
unterbrechung die regierung stellt der
christbaum die korruption ist ein
grundpfeiler dieses systems in dem ist
der frelimo partei bisher immer gelangen
sich an der wahl zu halten
der direktor eines zum beispiel ist
nicht direkter geworden ist
nein er ist rektor geworden aber der
parteitreue lässt die verantwortlichen
dort hören ihm machen was und so
versichern viele hilfsgelder in dubiosen
kanälen angeblich sind durch die
korruption in den vergangenen zehn
jahren um 600 millionen euro
verschwunden
hilfsorganisationen wie die mission
zentrale der franziskaner aus bonn
stellen deshalb vor ort sicher dass die
spendengelder gut angelegt sind und
machen sich ein bild vom fortschritt
ihrer projekte in mehr als 70 ländern
weltweit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
150.000 euro sind zum beispiel schon in
den wiederaufbau dieser sekundarschule
in bar geflossen
jugendliche im alter von zwölf bis 20
jahren werden hier unterrichtet
auch wenn einige klassenzimmer noch
immer verwaist sind die schule wurde
stark zerstört das dach wurde abgedeckt
das sieht man hier
wir haben viel verloren viel wurden
bücher in der bibliothek wurden das
ganze mehr material zerstört
einige bücher haben wir nicht mehr
und was ist bis heute getan worden
wir haben uns über die deutsche hilfe
gefreut als die hilfe kam haben wir aber
gesehen dass es nicht reicht wir müssen
die dächer noch abdecken ich langsam
sollten wir die schule wieder auf auch
wenn es hier gerade keinen betonmischer
gibt die bauarbeiter klotzen ran und
werden im zweifel einfach zu
menschlichen betonmischer endlich findet
der unterricht für die 500 schülerinnen
und schüler wieder regelmäßig statt
auch wenn es an der schule noch sehr
beengt
es gibt zu wenig klassenräume die das
ganze überstanden haben
die räume sind einfach zu voll es gibt
noch platz auch schwierig direktor hat
kein arbeitszimmer
hier haben können sekretariat wie
stellst du dir in diesem land deine
zukunft vor meine persönliche zukunft
ich möchte psychologin werden den
menschen helfen
nach dem zyklon hätte ich zum beispiel
helfen können viele menschen sind
traumatisiert
ich hätte ihnen helfen können das ganze
besser zu begreifen die lage besser zu
verstehen was für eine zukunft haben die
kinder in diesem land in mosambik
ich denke die schule bestimmt unsere
zukunft ohne schule haben wir gar keine
zukunft keine organisierte die meisten
kinder in mosambik gehen heute zumindest
fünf jahre lang zur schule doch noch
immer kann fast jeder zweite erwachsene
nicht lesen oder schreiben
und nach wie vor arbeiten die meisten
menschen auf dem feld oder verkaufen
ihre waren auf dem markt etwa 80 prozent
der menschen in mosambik leben von der
landwirtschaft die gibt es obst zu
kaufen gemüse kohle zum kochen
geräucherten fisch und es gibt
secondhand klamotten viele davon aus
europa ein baby strampler und t shirt
kostet umgerechnet 25 cent außerdem im
angebot
wörtlich übersetzt aus dem
portugiesischen fisch der aussieht wie
schulen während die meisten menschen in
mosambik von der landwirtschaft leben
haben ausländische investoren vor allem
die bodenschätze des landes im visier
sagt der deutsche unternehmer philip
büchler
er betreut das mosambik geschäft für
eine dänische spedition laufen welche
chancen sehen sie in dem land in
mosambik also dass das das landes reich
an bodenschätzen und wir haben also
kohle
im internet wir haben die das kraft wir
haben also das beste grad im norden
dass es wird zwei großen minen sind und
angeblich ist die qualität einer der
besten auf der welt das hat sehr viel
potenzial da wurde sehr viel investiert
und die projekte werden wahrscheinlich
ist er los gehen
ich glaube aber persönlich selber der
größte wie man auch im englischen sagt
in mainz der das land wirklich nach
vorne bringen sind die die die gas
das passt im norden gefunden wurde und
da sind große investitionen im moment
und also vom frachtaufkommen im
logistischen sagen wir werden fünf
millionen fracht und jahren durch musik
fließen und das ist enorm
die wirtschaftlichen chancen muss am bix
scheint vor allem china zu sehen bei
unseren fahrten durchs land kommen wir
ständig an chinesischen fabriken
supermärkten und tankstellen vorbei sind
definitiv die meisten chinesen die große
investitionen geleistet haben sehr viel
investiert haben und im detail regionen
geholfen haben mit infrastrukturen
straßen auch hier in bar
der wiederaufbau der straßen die
natürlich interesse haben an den eigenen
rohstoffen und da müssen wir jetzt mal
voraus sehen wie weit das reguliert wird
danach kommen die amerikaner die das gas
wollen und juristen rücken nach also das
wird auf jeden fall interessanter
brennpunkt und wichtig zu sehen wie es
politisch von mosambik und der
internationalen community nachher
reguliert wird
dass der kuchen gut aufgeteilt wird aber
viel wichtiger dass natürlich die
menschen hier man darf nicht vergessen
wir leben in einer der ärmsten länder
ärmsten länder nicht nur in afrikas und
auf der welt in der tat zählt mosambik
zu den zehn ärmsten ländern der welt
am eindrucksvollsten sehen wir dass bei
einer suppenküche für kinder eine gruppe
von müttern kocht ehrenamtlich für
waisenkinder im freien weil der zyklon
auch hier die küche zerstört hat die
küche ist eingestürzt
dieser pavillon ebenfalls
wir haben einen wassertank hier oben wir
haben auch fließend wasser
die küche können wir jetzt nicht
reparieren lassen ein junge kann es kaum
erwarten
aber er ist heute früh jeden tag kommen
200 kinder im alter von fünf bis
fünfzehn zur suppenküche 200 von 1,5
millionen waisen in mosambik
das problem viele von ihnen haben keine
geburtsurkunde und damit keinen
staatlichen schutz vor kinderarbeit
missbrauch oder dem dienst an der waffe
noch nie haben wir kinder gesehen die
sich so sehr über eine suppe freuen
ich höre gern das wort gottes und esse
gerne hier ist die super lecker super
lecker es ist erschreckend zu sehen was
hier noch zu tun ist wenn man hier durch
die straßen fährt wenn man ankommt die
zerstörten dächer dinge hier gewiss
scheint alles ein wenig still zu stehen
und im blick das jetzt wieder die
regenzeit kommt sollen die decke wieder
in ordnung sein denn auch der regen
zerstört die häuser für die menschen
malaria ist damit verbunden
ich glaube ja beide ist ein bisschen für
mich mein eindruck eine vergessene stadt
und wir gehen die menschen damit um die
armen halten zusammen und das ist
wirklich berühren wie sie da und für
mich auch habe kein leid volles gesicht
gesehen die gejammert hätten oder
unzufrieden waren sie sie leben in
dieser situation aber ja die armen sie
strahlen etwas noch auch ein
lebensfreude hier wohl im wissen dass
sie wirklich schweres im hintergrund zu
ertragen haben als wir die köchin fragen
wo die waisenkinder leben sprechen sie
immer wieder von einem hotel eine frau
bietet an uns auf der ladefläche ihres
wagens mitzunehmen
und uns die behausungen der kids zu
zeigen es beginnt eine holprige fahrt
über schlaglochpisten 20 minuten später
stehen wir vor diesem gebäude das ist
hier wirklich ein verstörender ort ein
ehemaliges gran hotel aus kolonialzeit
noch in der nähe des strandes dass es
irgendwann verfallen und heute leben
hier hunderte menschen sind sehr viele
waisenkinder die zum teil mit ihren
großeltern ihr leben aber auch zyklon
opfer die ihre häuser verloren haben das
krasse ist es gibt zwischen einigen
etagen keine treppenhäuser mehr
das heißt die leute müssen von außen in
ihre behausungen klettern dann sagt uns
die köche noch das hier öfter kinder
beim toben vom dach stürzen weil es
keine absperrung liebt das bild dieses
schrecklichen ort lässt uns auf der
rückreise aus mosambik nicht los
[Musik]
mittlerweile erfahren wir von einer
neuen hiobsbotschaft auf jessicas
familie das mädchen das mit ihren beiden
schwestern ohne eltern lebt und deren
haus der sturm zerstörte dem etat die
jüngste der drei ist hiv positiv so
viele kinder in mosambik
alle drei sind dank spendengeldern in
einem katholischen internat in kelly
mahner untergekommen 300 kilometer
nördlich von berra die einrichtung ist
auf hiv kranke kinder spezialisiert und
jessica sie studiert jetzt
personalmanagement an der universität
der stadt immerhin ein hoffnungsschimmer
in einem land das auch ein jahr nach
zyklon idee nicht wieder auf die beine
gekommen ist